in the u.s lawmakers have presented
fresh evidence of donald trump's efforts
to overturn his 2020 election defeat a
committee is investigating whether
trump's false claims about the result
led to the storming of the capital on
january 6 2021.
in the third public hearing the panel
shared evidence that trump tried to
force his vice president mike pence to
overturn the election result
pursuant to the constitution he was not
present in person at the hearing but
former u.s vice president mike pence was
at the center of it nonetheless
the house select committee which has
spent a year investigating the january 6
attack on the u.s capitol presented
never before seen evidence showing how
former president donald trump led a
campaign to pressure pence to overturn
his 2020 election defeat
donald trump wanted mike pence
to do something no other vice president
has ever done
the former president wanted pence to
reject the votes and either declare
trump the winner or send the votes back
to the states to be counted again
according to testimony trump pressured
his vice president in private but also
publicly
like in this tweet posted the day before
the riot which reads the vice president
has the power to reject fraudulently at
chosen electors
pence didn't follow trump's demands
aware that he did not have the power to
overthrow the election result as
explained by his legal counsel greg
jacob
after four and a half no vice president
in 230 years of history had ever claimed
to have that kind of authority
pence's refusal to go along with trump's
plan could have cost him dearly
this footage played at the hearing shows
rioters at the capitol calling for his
death
[Applause]
it was revealed for the first time that
the attackers came within 40 feet around
12 meters of pence and his family while
they were being escorted to safety by
his secret service detail
the hearing also presented further
evidence that donald trump and his legal
adviser john eastman knew that their
plan to invalidate the election result
was historically unprecedented and most
importantly illegal but they went ahead
with it anyway
according to this email shown by the
panel eastman even asked to receive a
presidential pardon after the riot three
more public hearings are planned by the
committee to lay out their findings the
focus is expected to remain on the
evidence alleging that trump knowingly
broke the law while in office and on
retracing the series of events that led
to the unprecedented attack on u.s
democracy
for more let's welcome jim ropinold he's
a lawyer a u.s presidential historian
and an expert on the 1972 watergate
scandal he joins us now from cleveland
ohio welcome to dw gem many have been
calling for trump to be indicted over
the january six insurrection
to do that prosecutors would have to
prove criminal intent that trump knew
what he was doing was wrong and went
ahead and did it anyway based on the
case this committee's made so far do you
see any evidence of that
yes hello michael thanks for having me
yesterday was a turning point uh vice
president pence's attorney greg jacobs
connected the dot and
for criminal intent clearly
uh trump was told what he wanted to do
the scheme that was put together by this
guy named eastman was illegal
he knew it was illegal he was told
repeatedly it was illegal and yet he he
went forward with it so
i think the dots have been connected
here and and that there is sufficient
proof of criminal intent uh by the the
former president to try and stop uh the
peaceful transfer of power and there are
multiple felonies that that gets
involved into
how likely is it uh trump will get
indicted let alone convicted
well you know it's a it's a good
question and i i would pose the question
the other way around what would happen
in this country if he's not indicted um
this evidence is compelling with richard
nixon we got tapes to show he was
involved in criminal activity now we
have with trump insiders and a lot of
them saying the same thing that what he
was doing was illegal and
we really need to have the political
will to bring this indictment because
this is criminal activity at the highest
level
and it really just cannot go
unaccounted for
a lot of powerful testimony at
thursday's hearing including from
retired federal judge michael ludwig i
want to get your reaction to what some
might describe as one of the more
chilling statements he made
donald trump
and his
allies and supporters
are a clear and present danger
to american democracy
not mincing words there do you agree
with that statement sir
a hundred percent uh and this is a very
conservative judge
um who is a very thoughtful guy
you can see how deliberately he speaks
but what he's saying is absolutely true
which is january 6 was bad but but it's
worse now because we we look back a year
and a half later and people still
believe the big lie they still believe
this was not a big deal and they're
telling us that in 2024 if this happens
again
they they will they will attempt this
again and they could very easily succeed
so
i think he is exactly right this is a
very precarious
moment for american democracy
jim in the half minute we have left here
i want to ask you one more question
today marks the 50th anniversary of
watergate a monumental political scandal
that forced the resignation of president
richard nixon of course based on what
you've seen so far years from now how
will this current scandal stack up to
watergate by comparison
uh this scandal is uh by many factors
worse than watergate
watergate was a true problem and i don't
mean to minimize it it was abuse of
power nixon did a number of things
including in foreign affairs that were
really egregious
but this is a president who not only was
going after
democracy itself to stay in power he
literally was scheming and happy to see
his own vice president assassinated in
that process
you cannot imagine a worse scenario in
my view and this is much much worse than
watergate
jim ropanold lawyer u.s presidential
historian many many thanks sir
thank you michael good to see you
you